to be fair I was only there for four  days because the hurricane came the next  day and we didn't go back I mean I had a  friend that he went there and he did the  whole thing he was traveling back and  forth to Florida every weekend two  flights a week every week for the whole  year so he could keep his his thing I  was like do you think if you didn't have  a hundred flights a year you would be  able to make up the 30 that you're  paying in Texas and I was like and I was  like and you'd be able to just live  where you want to live there's a part of  me that just loves making more money and  I would prefer to pay fewer taxes like I  would but I think that her logic is  sound which is why have all the money in  the world if you can't live where you  want to live in the world that's kind of  the big picture at least for me